panel today on bridging from Academia to
practice particularly in the non-profit
and public sectors so we're really
delighted to have a wonderful group of
panelists including a virtual panelist
with us here today and will be moderated
by Professor bahide is an associate
professor of operations at Yale School
of Management her research is on a
matching Market platform design often in
both public and private sectors and so
she's just a wonderful moderator for us
today so handing it over too
thanks I think
um
good afternoon everyone Welcome to our
panel discussion we are delighted to
have you with us and also we are honored
to have five great panelists uh covering
a wide range of applications in the
public sector
so I'm going to start by introducing our
panelists very briefly and then we're
gonna jump right into the discussion
I want to start by saying that all of
our panelists are extremely accomplished
but to keep this introduction short I'm
gonna
mainly skip most of their
accomplishments and titles and so on so
apologies for that in advance just in
the interest of that
all right with that I'm gonna go
alphabetically
today we have with us keyboard Focus who
is the Robert docson assistant professor
of a decision sciences and operations at
USC Marshall
uh on his 30 days he works on uh he
works on operation of complex Network
systems on his apply applied days he
helps his home country and by serving as
the chief data scientist for the Greek
national covid scientific task force and
for his work on designing a targeted
testing systems for covet he won a
number of prestigious Awards
Timon thanks for being here with us
today
we are also honored to have moon duchen
with us and she's a professor of
mathematics at Tufts University and she
runs the redistricting lab which is an
awesome interdisciplinary research group
that focuses on data for democracy and
uses a variety of tools from different
disciplines ranging from mathematics to
law to policy to build models for
elections and redistricting Association
great and influential work in this area
and we're very happy to have her
uh we also have Philip Lecrae with us
and he's an operations research analyst
at the U.S Census Bureau and he works
mainly in the area of differential
privacy and in the past few years he has
served as the internal scientific league
on the project for modernizing the
disclosure avoidance system that has
been used in the first two major
releases for the decennial census
uh yeah we are also very happy you made
it in the last last second
usually we have Samir shop with us uh
Samir is the vice president of
partnership and customer success at
volunteer match it has contributed to a
vision of developing the global digital
volunteering platform and he uses
technology and networks and data to
empower volunteers and non-profits and
governments
it's actually graduates of Berkeley it
would have been great to have him in
person but unfortunately he couldn't be
here but they're still very happy to
have you uh visually
the
last but of course not least we have
Alex table tatel boy who is an associate
professor of Economics at University of
Oxford his research lies in Market
design and the economics of Networks
as well as their applications in
environmental economics and energy
markets he's the co-founder of an
awesome organization you should check it
out called
refugee.refugees.ai that develops new
technology for refugees
so much great to have you and once again
thank all the panelists
and with that let me first tell you a
little bit about our plan
so we're gonna start with a couple of
questions that we prepared uh beforehand
and shared with the audience that with
with our finalists
but of course we reserve the Beast of
time towards the end for Q a uh from the
audience
that's it during even the first part if
you have if you'd like to make a point
if you have some relevant experience
you'd like to share if you have any
question by all means feel free to jump
in we'd love to keep this Interactive
okay
good
so with that let me start with a
question that might be on the minds of a
few folks in the audience
and this is mainly targeted to our
toward academics
um
in our community working with a private
sector companies is now pretty common
many of the participants of This
research program have experience working
with a private sector and they might be
wondering what are some of the key
differences uh in terms of working with
a private sector company versus a public
sector entity
maybe we can start with Alex but others
are very welcome to join too
um I'm a bit sad that you told everybody
that the questions were prepared I I
have this answer and I was hoping that
all of you would think I came up with it
on the spot uh but I had some time to
think about it
um so um I so I've worked with both
private and uh uh uh non-profit
companies and governments and I I guess
the one way of framing the answer is uh
which might be uh be easy for most
people and the audience is I think the
main differences are about objectives
and constraints so uh the way I think I
sort of think about it is that in the
private sector
um I work both with sort of startups and
larger organizations the objectives are
usually both measurable and sort of
straightforward to kind of um you know
that they can be measured and they can
be sort of explained and compared to one
another so you know typically think
about sales and profit and so on and so
the organization at least as a whole
would typically have uh an objective
that you can sort of recognize and get
behind
in the in the non-profit sector the
objective is not typically completely
clear so while you might have something
that is a mission statement very often
and so you might see you know an
organization work with you know tries to
help refugees but exactly how is it
trying to help you use what does it mean
to help refugees how do you improve a
livelihood of a person right that's a
kind of a more you know General and kind
of difficult to uh to measure pointed so
a lot of it ends up being discussing and
understanding what the objectives are
and and often actually kind of pointing
out that sometimes objectives can be in
Conflict it's not something that
typically organizations don't understand
but it's often I think as academics
we're often good at thinking about you
know trade-offs and and precise
measurement we can help out
the other side I think that is uh uh
kind of the the other side of that this
big difference is is the constraints so
obviously a lot of private companies a
lot of the companies that the folks in
the audience uh uh would have interacted
with they just don't really have a lot
of constraints when it comes to money
um so you know amazing talks from folks
who've worked in Google Apple you know
tech companies large tech companies I
mean to A first order this is just kind
of financial constraints it's not what
comes to mind the moment you move into
the non-profit sector there is no money
I mean really you have to um I mean
you're scrambling for you know ten
thousand pound grants or ten thousand
sorry well actually the same thing ten
thousand dollar Grant
um so so Things become really tough
you've got to really think about you
know resources in terms of both kind of
human uh resources you know how many
people you can have working on a project
uh how much uh you can kind of
realistically you know spend
um and so this sort of changes the
interaction that you would have often
you are thinking about yourself as as
being a volunteer are not you know
really kind of giving up your time
literally for free because often this
time would not be you know kind of
directly compensated anyway the other
type of constraints that comes up and
that's especially when you're working
with the government is uh obviously
there's political constraints and
sometimes they're not actually properly
explained right uh so there might just
be some sort of tacit understanding that
uh certain things just don't go very
well and maybe this is a British
government thing but even my interaction
with the American government uh things
are not always clear about what the
political constraints are and so
a lot of the work ends up navigating
through these kind of very difficult
exceptionally frustrating sort of uh
constraints and you sort of have to
prepare yourself for this and I think
one of the great things about being an
academic actually and and doing this so
you often have a lot of time not
literally in the moment but you have a
lot of time that you can wait out and
actually wait for the constraints to be
relaxed a little bit at some point and
so this is I think kind of the main
difference is you know with a private
company usually you can do things
quickly you can measure things easily
and you get frustrated I think
ultimately a lot less in terms of the
kind of the the process working with
ngos and the government things are
harder to measure it's a lot less clear
often with the objectives after you know
cayman's work things work I think I
guess much easier to measure but very
often it's kind of hard to Define
ultimately what we're doing and the
frustration of trying to overcome just
this huge number of of completely
irrational that's the issue of often
irrational but just present constraints
can be very frustrating I hope that's a
good Framing and maybe resonates with
some folks from the uh uh
great thanks so much
um
yeah I would just add transparency
um so so some of the work that I am
thinking of here is I've done a bunch of
work
um with independent redistricting
Commissions in this cycle or with
legislatures or with different kinds of
bodies that were connected to
redistricting and
um
often there's a huge variable which is
the transparency switch so many of these
independent commissions are actually
doing the work of negotiation and
decision making on a live stream
and that's just such a different Dynamic
than the smoke-filled room that A
legislature can work in and now having
done both kinds
um that's it just makes an enormous
difference on how the work plays out
another variable in the mix
thank you
so in terms of differences I I mean I
work in a very different environments
from what I was used to and politics as
what said is
very very complex to navigate
I think I have a very short temper for
those that know me and like there are a
couple of things so I'm saving you Time
by tackling the second question too in
terms of differences uh that like I
remember me blowing up uh the first one
is like when you work with politicians
you have to realize that their job
their job is to stay relevant and the
moment you go in there and you're
proposing something that works suddenly
they may not be relevant anymore and
that creates a huge conflict
and like the second one that I found
extremely upsetting and different from
the way we think about it like if we
give to any one of you prove that
information is good
uh you would say okay I have an
optimization problem I add more
information I can always copy the
previous solution hence information is
good but then where you when you talk
with like fully patients information
comes with inability to claim the
deniability
so and this is for me and like for my
team which was hamster and Vishal
very very hard to navigate and that was
another one difference from the academic
world
yeah all right all right uh Philip or
Samir any any thoughts
I think I think some of some of what uh
what was said already does resent it
with me a little bit
um
for me it's not so much that the
constraints throughout the process of
developing those those are avoidance
system which is my primary work in this
area
um for the tour of the 2020 census uh
the the constraints on the system where
intentionally pass it um or or that they
were deeply ambiguous it was more that
I I think moving into an area that's
more highly formal like differential
privacy
um as opposed to the much more informal
methods that the view has been used for
just disclosure avoidance historically
this is forced the bureau to contend
with a lot of assumptions that have been
made sort of tacitly and never really
very explicitly discussed
um one of the the ones that was most
difficult to deal with is that
um
a strong implicit assumption throughout
the bureau when you're talking about the
the big every 10-year decennial census
um is that it is the gold standard it's
supposed to have the most accurate data
people are just accustomed to thinking
but as having essentially nowhere that's
not true there are a number of forms of
error that are Quantified to greater or
lesser degrees
um but when you there's a large paradigm
shift that came with going to the folks
responsible for trying to ensure the
quality of the final tabulations we
output
um and saying hey how much error would
be acceptable in this particular
tabulation for the kinds of things that
you expect it to be used for that's just
not a question people have ever really
confronted in the past because their
answer was always zero there should be
no error there
um and then that kind of paradigm shift
I I think was was probably the biggest
thing I saw as far as the issue of Casa
assumptions going on here I don't really
have any direct experience um in working
for non-profits I'm more in Academia uh
since I pretty much shifted immediately
out of grad school so I can't comment
really so much on the other side of
things maybe one other that's relevant
though uh that some prior comments
sparked for me was that the budget
situation is very interesting um at
least in my experience just inside
census uh mostly in that it it bounces
around radically project to project
um and really what determines how much
you have in terms of financial resources
to Fair around in a problem
um is are you on the decennial census or
are you on a relatively small project
that's that's contracted for and paid
for by a specific agency
right I mean money budget here privacy
budget is another even more deeply
complicated and newer issue uh that was
a lot more thorns in it that we'll
probably talk about in a little bit um
and tomorrow
um but there's also there are other
constraints that you don't face in
Academia Academia it's easy to walk down
the hall and just talk to a professor
who's an expert um in some area that
you're not immediately familiar with and
try to spark up a collaboration on
whether you choose to do that or not
it's sort of a freedom that you have uh
in government access to folks who are
direct experts in DP at least currently
is really relatively limited
um and and at least in our project and
I'm guessing this is going to be a
fairly common experience of governments
that try to adopt this kind of thing a
lot of the effort is just Auto didactic
it's like teaching yourself all of this
stuff and trying to get to the point
where you feel competent enough to do it
hi very nice thank you uh oh if I could
add yeah just um what Alex was saying
actually
um really Nails a lot of I think what I
feel like is also the difference is and
um so volunteer match we
um basically help people find a place to
volunteer and volunteering itself is
giving your time away for free and so
you know how do you measure that
um uh effectively so definitely like
having clear objectives and measurement
um is Def is a challenge and then on top
of that
um having very constrained resources to
the degree where
um some very basic things that we should
have been doing weren't possible to
actually vaida and her colleague showed
up and helped us
um so that that that is another point
and then the politics aspect is really
interesting too because we have
different stakeholders
um one of the main main ways we earn
revenue is through Partnerships with
corporations and so
um there there's a whole realm of
politics around volunteering uh related
to what is desired from the corporate
sector uh and what you might call
employee volunteering
um versus what nonprofits actually need
in terms of volunteers for the missions
they're um trying to
Undertake and I also appreciate the
comment from Moon about transparency
which you know just kind of filters into
all of that
um
the constrained resources really do have
such an impact on uh some of the ability
to yeah just have a lot of clarity with
how you can make an impact
all right great thank you so much Samir
uh any comments from the audience yes
yes so I really appreciated the comment
about the non-profits about constraints
and a few years ago
oh yes so I'd really appreciate a
comment about non-profit but I would
have wanted to hear more about the
market on the nonprofit so a few years
ago I was working with some non-profits
about humanitarian informatics and I was
like okay the work I'm doing for you is
it actually going to help the guy in
Aleppo or is it just going to help you
get more money because they do get money
right the the non-profits get money from
the philanthropists and they want the
promise not I need XYZ and so I think
especially for the young people it's
helpful to know that there is a market
as an economist Market among the
non-profits and it's not like they
infight right to get that money whatever
pot of money there is
thank you
um yeah so uh it's certainly true that
uh that uh ngos would typically be in
competition for funds and so uh I I
think one of the ways in which they now
try to stand out is by having high
quality collaborations with academics I
I have no doubt that the collaboration I
had with the U.S Refugee resettlement
agency was used in order to raise more
funding but given that I aligned with
their mission
I was happy with that right and I think
this is part of the kind of subtlety of
working with ngos is that often it does
become a personal thing I'm sure for you
know kimon for example there was also a
personal thing right and so it might not
be the same uh if you're helping Google
sell more ads which might still be you
know fulfilling and challenging in many
ways right but you might not align with
the mission in the same way as you do
and and I you know it might not work for
every NGO that you work with or indeed
every government that you work with for
sure but I think there is definitely a
much more personal connection right and
so when you end up with these kind of
feedbacks actually maybe they're okay
right that's kind of not a I sort of
didn't mind if you like being used in
that way uh to kind of to raise money
actually yeah let me jump in on that for
a second so
um the way that money circulates in the
election space has been a real
eye-opening for me and you can't
understand it without thinking about the
money
um on one hand so uh some years ago I
was on a national Academy's
um committee on voting security
um and was just I it was fascinating to
learn how the landscape of vendors who
make the machines that we vote on all
the different you know Market incentives
around that and how difficult it is to
improve because of the some ossification
in that market you can't understand it
without that when it comes to
redistricting I had no idea until I got
into the trenches just how many Bush
millions of dollars change hands around
redistricting especially after every
census comes out it's it's crazy and
there are many many vendors who take
Census Bureau products and package them
and sell them back to the public right
it and or not just to public but to
campaigns and two so there's this huge
kind of
um third party
space of people monetizing public
information in different ways and you
know we don't have time to go into that
but just to say you're absolutely right
to point to that as something you cannot
understand
the Dynamics without seeing um the flow
of money and the people whose incentives
want to prevent uh reform
right great uh Samir is there something
you'd like to ask because I think you
might have some experience
um
yeah I mean it's I think it's just a
tough question of or maybe it goes back
to what Alex was saying to Korean about
you know how do you measure
um in the space of the nonprofit world
one one thing you know just to
um so volunteer match we're mainly
focused on the United States
um the nonprofit sector in the United
States is much larger than anywhere else
in the world and uh in many ways you
might think of it just compare it
directly to the entire for-profit sector
there's that kind of diversity in the
nonprofit sector so
um when you're talking about markets
it's uh that complicated actually uh so
there's so many different possible
markets um volunteer match itself uh we
consider ourselves a Marketplace uh
where you know non-profits can post
volunteer opportunities and any
potential volunteer can come there and
find them and so there's all kinds of
Dynamics created around volunteering
itself and how
um you know what's formal what's not
formal
um yeah there's so much so much there
really uh that um I don't think there's
any way to uh you know simplify it
actually at this stage
all right great
um any other comments or questions
before we move on to another topic yes
then yes
so maybe I should ask
go ahead
so one question that I'd have for both
the academic and the non-academic parts
of the panel
um as we think about academics
collaborating with the non-profit sector
it seems to me like there would be two
versions of uh probably they're an
infinite number of versions but two
broad categories of how this can come
about where one would be the academic
has written a paper and thinks they have
a solution for a class of problems that
exist in the world and they approach the
non-profit
or the academic approaches the
non-profit and says what is your biggest
problem and tries to figure out how to
solve it and in your respective
experiences which one of the two was it
or which one was closer to what it was
like how does one get from the
non-profit has the problem
to a solution in a way that actually
sort of aligns with the incentives of
both the academic and the non-profit
that's a great question yeah let's hear
from everyone yeah that's indeed a very
good question thanks so I'll start with
my experience I will not I don't have
the answer what's better but I'll tell
you my experience so the way that our
project happened is kovit has just
started we were in lockdown Grace
decides to open up the Border they
announced the initial plan and at that
point
you know my mind exploded with House of
optimal plan was uh so literally the way
it happened is I I sent an email to the
Prime Minister and the chief
epidemiologist saying you know this is
me this is who I am I did my thesis and
epidemics
tell me how you need my help because
it's very clear that the plan the
current plan is not at all data driven
it's not the best you could be doing
and then actually connections the
previous question because of their own
incentives creating like safety like the
plan you know looking as good as it can
that's where you can push the decision
makers to implement type of person that
can make an excellent contribution as
long as Epsilon is positive they have
nothing to lose right
yeah I I would probably even strengthen
kimon's point the paper it's always the
second basically I think so it's it I I
think ultimately uh you what you come
with is experience and skills and you
know your ability to solve problems
that's what people in this audience are
really good at but you're not there to
solve your problems you are there to
solve the organizer if you want to work
with the organization very often and
this is what I we're going to probably
come to this sorry to but you know this
is what I advise all of my graduate
students who want to do this you're not
there to implement your solutions to the
problems you think this organization has
your first job is to figure out what the
problems are and you will come with
amazing skill sets which will allow them
to solve these problems but your first
job is figuring out what the problem at
hand is and what you imagine the problem
is versus what the problem actually is
the gap is usually huge right and of
course there is a discussion about
whether the problem is a real problem
and so on right but ultimately I think
if you're going to work with an NGO
I think you should be solving helping
them solve their problems and kind of
get behind that that mission that I was
mentioning to in the past
so I think in the case of census there's
a little bit of evidence for both
directions having occurred
um maybe ultimately I will I will back
off of that in a second and say actually
I think it's mostly the second sort of
like Alex just said
um but but in this in this case there's
a little bit of number one going on uh
so census has a large number of
tabulations that are published that fall
really neatly into simple query classes
um and for the most part the few
products that I was responsible for um
helping develop the the algorithm to
handle
um we're actually explicitly designed to
say hey these These are the queries that
fit into simple counting query classes
that we know we have good methods for
from the DB literature already they
don't require some new revolutionary
technique to try to handle them most of
the hard stuff is all of the other
constraints that are being layered upon
us um that are not really about privacy
but are about sort of how the data
should look um The Feast validity of the
data and then dealing with the side
effects of that um and also dealing with
the computational problems at scale that
are caused in turn by those extra
environments uh but but really most of
the DP methods we used were pretty
direct imports from the DP literature
um and in that sense I think the tools
had been built to solve a problem we
looked and said oh that actually fits
our problem quite nicely and pulled them
in uh that being said there's also a
huge range of there's a huge range of
problems in the millennial census that
are not handled readily by methods that
are available in the DP literature um
and we kind of selectively carved out
those from the the project statement
very very early on and said okay these
are things that are going to acquire a
completely different approach
um we'd like to spend time on that but
we have enough problems dealing with
these extra constraints that have been
thrown at us that are not really about
privacy on this first group of products
so we push those to the side
um fast forward a few years and now now
we're in sort of a point in time where
um somewhat Labs who I don't think we
have a representative from them here but
um they are a group of folks uh who are
are now sort of doing number the the
second of the two approaches uh we have
come to them and said hey we have the
specific space of problems that our high
sensitivity join queries and we don't
know how to handle them in a way
um that's going to give reasonable
accuracy and also give reasonably strong
privacy guarantees um so they sort of
developed book methods directly to try
to address that and this gets back into
kind of the them having a strong toolkit
in this area of Science and Mathematics
as Alex mentioned before
um I do think and this is why I said
I'll probably back off with the first
one a bit I think that first category
really was mostly successful in the case
of the census because the census is
almost
a large portion of it is almost the
ideal use case for for something like DP
it kind of like slots very yeah there
are a lot of complications
um that I would talk about mostly
tomorrow
um and a little bit uh I think in a
moment here um that that aren't
addressed in that way but my guess is
that as we move further away from those
very basic use cases that are the ones
that were direct most directly addressed
in in the theoretical literature early
on
um we're going to see primarily the
second of those two routes occurring
so but there's a different domain in
which
the peer-reviewed publication matters a
great deal and that's expert work in the
law right so
um I I'm actually not familiar at all
with how this is outside the US but in
the US the legal system there's
something called the dobbert standard
which means to qualify as an expert you
really need peer-reviewed Publications
so you know that's that's an interesting
wrinkle on the the whole like push and
pull of how to work with
um
you know how to work in the field
um
I think that
to write the most relevant kind of
scholarly article you should be talking
to stakeholders and listening to their
problems rather than starting with your
own framework but I just wanted to throw
that out as a as a wrinkle where it
really does matter what you got through
that whole process and out into them
all right great uh Samir I think yeah I
think that's a really good point and
just uh Echoes the idea that their
non-profit sectors are actually quite
diverse where you may need to employ
different tactics to
um be able to help but in our case it
was very much the the one that was
described where by the again showed up
and said hey we've got the skill set but
there was a question of um we don't know
what we don't know and
um luckily I guess a little bit similar
to the census although not with the
um amount of detail uh we we had data
data that uh by the team could actually
take and figure out ways to improve upon
the system that we had in place
all right great let me I should have
done this at the beginning but then we
disclosed that uh
samiran uh Samir Samir myself and
Daniela and our other collaborators have
an ongoing project it's been a great
working with volunteer match sorry
should have disclosed it at the
beginning
uh but that's great thanks Samir I want
to add one other last point to
Danielle's question which is I've been
thinking maybe that we should be having
a bit of more kind of a systematic way
to attract non-profit to come and talk
to uh academics right so lots of them
have problems it would be great if we do
have centers or some programs in which
we can increase the kind of interactions
create opportunities at least for more
interactions many of many of non-profits
may not know how much they can benefit
from uh from interacting with academics
so that would be also one idea to person
great we are still in question number
one right by the way but this is great
we covered a lot of other topics that we
yeah we were planning to cover
anything else
all right
if not
um
I want to start kind of looking ahead a
little bit I want to ask about future
and I want to ask both academics and
practitioners about whether the kind of
ripe opportunities that they foresee in
the future for bringing
the public sector and Academia closer
together
so maybe this time we started Philip
yeah
um so as usual I'll be drawing
specifically on the census context here
when I get my answer uh I think there
are a lot of things there are a lot of
theoretical issues that aren't handled
directly in a way that is particularly
well developed in the DP literature
right now um and yet are extremely
important in practice the laundry list
is pretty long but I'll start with the
one that I think is most pressing in
deploying a real world system I'm like
actually taking the theory building a
system
um and you know actually doing something
with that the the probably the biggest
difference between that and writing a
paper is you have to eventually choose
parameter settings that you can get the
internal and external stakeholders to
agree or at least not disagree too
loudly about is an acceptable choice of
settings in the census context the way
we've gone about that is to have the the
highest sort of privacy relevant
committee at census uh the status
stewardship executive policy committee
to make those final choices
um but there are a lot of complications
that come with saying hey they're the
right group of people to make the choice
that sort of balances privacy and
accuracy one of the most fundamental
ones is that they have to understand the
choice that they're making in the first
place when they pick a particular
privacy loss budget they have to be able
to say oh well I have an understanding
of what privacy standard it is or what
meaning I'm giving to the statement that
there is a strong or a weak privacy
guarantee of some kind and that turns
out to be shockingly difficult to do if
you just look at most of the DP
literature
um there really isn't a literature on
how to help a group of people especially
a group of people with very mixed
technical backgrounds and non-technical
backgrounds to go through the process of
picking parameter settings for an
algorithm
um there are lots of papers that say
well you know that seems kind of small
that seems kind of large here's a range
of parameter settings we sort of
explored but remains non-committal
ultimately about the sort of subjective
question of how you should finally pick
things
um
that there are also a few different
theoretical perspectives in the
literature um on how you can or should
interpret the Privacy guarantee and my
experience at least I don't think we
have nearly enough time to get into this
today but my experience in talking about
this fpp conferences and trying to annoy
people about it
um is that there often is disagreement
even within the DB Community about which
of these perspectives is the right one
but you don't actually discover that
until you've kind of gotten really into
the weeds and someone says something
they think is obvious that you think is
completely wrong
um and and then you end up kind of going
down this Rabbit Hole of oh well that's
what you thought the Privacy guarantee
should have been and what we should have
been communicating to people
um and not even just in the academic
literature either this is also something
that happened inside of census we had a
lot of arguments early on about what so
DP implies a few different kinds of
guarantees we had a lot of arguments
about which of those guarantees we
should be trying to take um and then
Express to this decision-making body
um something interesting that came up in
connection with us at a recent
conference about DP in in Toronto uh was
a discussion of well maybe one way we
should be trying to skirt around this
issue of attempting to explain the
theoretical nature of the guarantees to
decision-making bodies in a way that's
accessible is perhaps we should Instead
try to like gamify it maybe we should be
building small experimental setups um
such as maybe a little one so I think
Rachel's prior work although I think
most of the results I saw there were
negative so maybe maybe uh maybe it's
more of a matter of sort of trying to
figure out what assumptions we need to
make in order to justify this kind of
thing uh but but I feel like small scale
experimental um um almost like
behavioral game theoretic kind of setups
my might possibly be a way to justify
calibrating uh what we think at least
the Public's expectations are for what a
proper privacy accuracy trade-off is
maybe that's another way of getting
information that's more Concrete in
feeling to a decision-making body that
may consist heavily of non-technical
folks
um 100 for the mic in a sec but one
other thing I want to say about about
this particular issue is another major
difference and this is maybe less less
fundamental but in practice it's the way
things have worked out if you look at
the settings that are recommended to the
extent that you can find this at all in
the DB literature for privacy lost
budgets usually all you'll really find
is someone thinks that the budget should
be small the overall budget should be
very small if you then look at projects
in practice including the Das project
you'll find that budgets are not small
um at least not not when not when you
compare them to the recommendations in
the literature I'll talk I'll go into
more detail about this in my talk
tomorrow
um but I think this kind of creates a
pressing question which is I mean like
one reaction to this which is fine from
my perspective it is a reasonable
reaction is to say oh well then the
Privacy guarantee is terrible and we
need to try and pressure people they get
those budgets smaller and they maybe
look for algorithmic improvements so we
can get those watches smaller or new DP
Frameworks um that'll allow us to
justify making the budget smaller we're
interpreting them in a way that's
smaller another perspective to say well
okay but maybe there's more we can say
that's still provably meaningful comes
with some privacy guarantee but
selectively gives up on certain parts of
the worst case nature of differential
privacy
um and again that's something I'll get
into a little bit more tomorrow like
that that kind of question I think needs
more examination what do you do when you
have a large privacy lost budget do you
just give up and say it's
uninterpretable or it's not actually a
strong guarantee
um that is an answer but it's also a
dangerous answer because right now that
is kind of the reality of most most real
world implementations
all right great thank you I'm looking
forward to your talk tomorrow yes
like what are the topics that you're
most excited for this kind of
public sector Academia collaboration
looking forward
um well maybe I don't know about most
excited but there's a real challenge
coming up
uh so again in redistricting things have
changed a lot
um I was talking yesterday to
um Nate parsley who's the he's a law
professor at Stanford and he's the guy
in the country who drew your map
probably if your map was drawn by a
court he probably drew it right so he's
he's done a lot of that and he's been
doing redistricting for many cycles and
he's like some things change it's just
meaner
um and not only that but like both
sidesism has taken over a little bit and
so now it's very difficult even for a
court to appoint an expert without their
needing to be a balanced set of experts
somehow and academics are kind of
default colored Democratic just that's
how it is today and so you're seeing
these weird things happening where like
the um
Virginia commission had a
um Professor Who's Bernie groffman who's
been doing this for many years and then
they put a blogger up against him
because he was associated with
Republicans and then the Ohio commission
deadlocked so the court appointed a
professor on one side and a
um
um I'm trying to think of
so self-employed consultant I don't know
I don't I'm just trying to think of the
right nice language
um to be the other side the Arizona
independent commission brought me in to
explain
how differential privacy was not going
to ruin the Census Data but then they
were told they needed someone on the
other side
um and so they brought in a guy who's a
consultant again runs his own consulting
company and whose punch line was so I
want to knows I love this example he
actually had a slide
with us still from Apocalypse Now of a
Napalm dropping helicopter and said the
Census Bureau has decided they need to
destroy the data in order to save it
um and then the end of his talk was but
you can always buy data from me instead
right and so but there's this kind of
both sidesism and unfortunately Academia
is being kind of put on one side of the
American political aisle which is really
a problem so I don't know if this is
something I'm excited about
um
it's an interesting shift
um and you know we obviously everybody's
thinking about trust and kind of trust
and experts that's something that we're
all talking and thinking about
um but I'm watching that change the
Norms in real time and redistricting
just as I got into it experts and
academics started to get colored as only
one side and so there's there's
something interesting to be done there
but I'm not sure what it is
okay
all right
can I ask a follow-up question about
this story like did you like have a
disclaimer at the start of your
testimony about like I don't consider
this interlocutor or credible like how
did you think about uh
I don't know like whether or not to
participate in this and whether or not
like you're sort of um
I don't know enabling bad faith
exercise you're getting lots of really
good exercise
um I uh I've been asked a bunch of times
in the cycle whether I'm willing to be
put up as the Democratic blah blah blah
for blah blah blah and I always say no
so I really resist being painted that
way I mean also because that's not how I
think about my role or where my heart is
in in the story but it's just very
difficult you find that you're
automatically automatically civil rights
perspective is conflated with the
Democratic party perspective which is a
mistake but you know so it's really hard
to resist as to sort of whether to say
this this other guy's a fraud you just
can't do that in this space also he's a
nice guy just you know so it's it's It's
Tricky we can talk offline
all right thank you alexandrimon uh yeah
I mean the legal system's an ugly place
um I I just want to go at your question
at a very high level if that's all right
and sort of say what it really excites
me I think
um I kind of a very broad thing I think
it's what that you refer to as
humanitarian informatics is a kind of
cool way of putting it and you know you
know we've called it before mechanism
designed for vulnerable populations but
it's ultimately using you know
technology and data to help marginalize
populations and the reason why I'm
excited about this is because you know
in a in a building like this cloud
computing and data and cool algorithms
you've been taking it for granted for 15
years you go into an NGO
um we were joking about this but getting
stuff on an Excel spreadsheet is kind of
a big deal and like this what's amazing
is that stuff is moving on to
spreadsheets which is great because once
it's on a spreadsheet you can you can do
things to it and so just generally
measuring what's going on you know uh
you know you know the kind of cases I'm
thinking of you know helping the
homeless drug addicts
um you know refugees
people who need social housing you know
really just populations that just
haven't been covered with data and ads
and things like that and so where I
think the huge change is happening and
where I think you know folks here in
this room who you know who have the
right skills you know that's where the
if you like the first you know with that
curve where you get returned for the
amount of stuff you put in you're right
at the beginning you kind of put a tiny
amount of effort and the payoff is just
massive so I think this is where I would
go the second place if I may that's what
I'm most excited about and this is also
a part kind of data slash technology uh
uh stuff is kind of environmental space
a lot of
for a long time uh people were going out
into a field and like measuring beetles
and they were saying oh my God the
Beatles are disappearing and now you can
measure stuff at scale and you can get
satellites and you can get these kind of
amazing Technologies you can measure
stuff and we know what's going on with
our nature finally and that's kind of
opening people's eyes to what's going on
and it kind of means that about policies
and mechanisms and whatever and ways of
trying to uh trying to you know stop
nature degradation so I think admittedly
very self-serving things I'm interested
in too but it just seems like you know
anywhere you poke in these spaces the
payoff just seems massive so I would I
would encourage folks to uh to spend
time on them
for me what I'm currently looking at and
I'm very passionate about for personal
and not personal reasons is uh Hawaii
fires and fires and similar to what Alex
Alex was saying there is a lot of
low-hanging fruits there were many easy
things that you can do that are order
one and there is like relating to
incentives uh that's again political and
monetary incentives it's one of these
cases where they're very aligned not
fully but they're very aligned so it's
uh getting to impact is easier and also
something that I personally like that's
my style the problems are very well
defined uh so yeah that's what I'm
excited about
right Samir
um
so first thing is just the um first two
panelists that spoke everything around
privacy and uh very interested in what
developments can take place there and
how that at least for volunteer match
um I think that's a critical component
because we are helping basically entire
nonprofit sector
um find volunteers and what kind of
impact they can make
um is it's going to be easier for us to
help those non-profits if we can get
people to give us their data and how to
do that in a way
um
that they feel comfortable
um very very curious about and we'll
probably be following up with you on it
uh perhaps still if that's okay
um
so uh then the the second point that
Alex brought up uh you know technology
and data
um that's exactly what we're doing and
there's so much need across the board
um there's non-profits that are much
better funded than ours that are doing a
better job in that I would say uh
because they've been able to build up
those capacities internally I I'd be
curious I don't know the answer to this
but be curious
um what um help they've had just from
colleagues that I have on LinkedIn
um I definitely see that there's
connections that I think are happening
between academics and non-profits um
some of those ones that I'm thinking of
so I can only imagine that's happening
um and there there is yeah there's such
a need there so
um I Echo that and same thing on the
environmental stuff
um yeah they're one of the things
um that's been really helpful since the
pandemic happened was we formed a
partnership with the state of California
and uh the work that we've done just
recently with uh Fida and Daniella who
sounds like is in the audience
um
uh it's actually allowing you know some
of those non-profits that um have gotten
more onto the network as uh the state of
California actually has a climate action
core so they're bringing on these
fellows some of that is helping directly
with some of the Wildfire work and
um having those non-profits be able to
find the volunteers they need more
effectively is a component of that we're
still really far away from
um like
long-term fantasy would be we would
actually be able to match uh supply and
demand directly like what are the needs
from the nonprofits what have they
identified how do you measure that
um and then it surfaces up to where you
know why do people go out and volunteer
it's uh you know I think fundamentally
there there's there's some extrinsic
stuff there for sure uh but
fundamentally it's intrinsic and so uh
that data that ability to understand
what kind of impact you're making is so
fundamental and so this goes across the
board for all nonprofits where they're
you know have a mission where they're I
think as mentioned drug addicts or
um yeah basically people that are have
been marginalized for all kinds of
different ways
um and then to that point like I'm very
curious about what
um basically since George Floyd was
murdered there was uh a
um Wellspring I guess of interest in
actually across the world around uh
marginalized people uh you know what's
being called at least in the corporate
sector like diversity Equity inclusion
and belonging
um yeah what yeah what can academics do
to help in that process of uh changing
the Dynamics of what has been happening
without the light being shown there
great thank you Samir any thought
s from the audience before we jump to
the last question
hi everyone I'm Priyanka grad student in
Northwestern
um I think my question is about sort of
the rhetorical challenges that you've
faced in your work and how you see some
of those
um sort of being solved moving forward
and in particular I think I'm thinking
about cases where like a word means a
specific thing to maybe academics like
when you say privacy or utility or
accuracy or whatever or transparency and
but then that word might take on a
different meaning when you're talking to
like a different group of people and so
like I guess I'm just interested to hear
your thoughts on this but also like
moving forward
um is there a way that we can like
collectively be more conscious about
like the meanings that we're sort of
assigning towards
I've got a great example for you because
I am it's it's quite funny so my uh my
uh uh kind of theory workers on a field
called matching markets which I'd used
um just com without thinking about it my
entire academic life and then I you know
offered to build a matching market for
this NGO and I discovered very quickly
that the word market is not a word you
want to use when you are talking about
matching refugees to local areas
um it turns out it has all sorts of
terrible connotations and for very good
reason and so you actually you know it's
it's kind of an interesting thing you
you do very quickly realize that the
words really matter and actually to the
point where if you don't adapt your
language quickly enough and you're not
cognizant what people are doing projects
can go
very quickly downhill because people
think your objectives are misaligned and
what you want to do is actually
different even though in your head
you're just kind of using lingo and so I
think your point is is crucial you have
to learn very very quickly and so now I
use matching systems
um those are good Everyone likes
matching systems systems are good in
general it seems um so people like
systems but you know you really have to
be very careful and I think especially
when you go into a kind of political
realm that becomes chemo probably has
great examples but that's when it
becomes very sensitive because now
you're suddenly kind of public Facebook
even inside an organization and an NGO
where people use very different kind of
language from what you would expect
inside say this building
yeah I also have a funny story to share
in that in that line so our work was a
reinforcement learning system so the
idea is that you know you have
exploitation you have exploration which
is like you allocate a test to a risky
country but then you want to allocate
the test to another country and then we
try to go there we show like nice
confidence intervals and like we are
allocating that many tests to the risky
one but then we're saving 100 tests to
explore
Communication Breakdown
no exploration so we say okay let us
think about it we go back we'll never
have a meeting we go back the next day
we have an index for you that calculates
risk for every country
that was it
so yeah I think you're a bad word so it
was this exploration exploitation
you don't want to mention any of this in
a meeting yes so any skindex and
everyone is sold so you you're you're
bringing a very good point
optimization
is actually really so I'm a
mathematician
um and I think even just between math
and CS there's a slightly different
valence to the word optimization I'm not
going to call it optimization unless you
can find the global Optimum right
um and in you know that's a big
misunderstanding out there about whether
it's possible to optimize right it sort
of makes sense does optimize just mean
try to get a little better
or does it mean find the best thing in
the world you know so that's just that's
that's even you know within Academia I
think people mean slightly different
things by it but I mean another quick
example and for those of you who are at
the Cs and law conference last week I
use this example there but as a
rhetorical challenge this this strikes
me as a super important one we have a
U.S Supreme Court right now that's
obsessed with race blindness
and with the idea that what is race
neutral is automatically Fair
and I I had the experience of testifying
in court in Pennsylvania
in in which I said the sentence well I
mean this is neutral but that doesn't
mean of course that it's fair and in
this room I think that would be
completely obvious and we could move on
to the next sentence but instead this
raised like Snickers and Chuckles around
the room because it seems so silly to
propose that something could be neutral
but not fair that is a big rhetorical
Gap that I am very preoccupied with
closing in in the the law and policy
space around the use of race this is
absolutely a court that is coming for
every
um use of race data and is really
ideologically opposed well I mean it was
ideologically opposed to the idea that
you might have to use race data to
achieve racially Fair outcomes
um and that's just going to I mean you
all know this probably because just you
know this term the affirmative action in
college admissions is back on the table
and the use of race data in actually all
kinds of election law is on the table
and it's either going to come down this
term or next year I mean it's coming
very soon to radically change all the
ways that
um government and public sector
continues race data and so it's just
imperative for us all to to work harder
on public-facing language that
differentiates neutrality from fairness
and I mean I know this is something that
many of us in the room think about all
the time but honing that language so
that it doesn't raise Chuckles in a room
full of lawyers seems like a important
pressing challenge
so I was trying to figure out while
everyone else was was giving great
responses whether I had anything further
to add to the Privacy issue because
Bianca really already took my primary
example
um
I I think the original question also was
like how do we see these being solved
I'm a little unsure so I know how I
would like the Privacy issue to be
solved I guess
um I would like to see the Privacy
Community come to a point where a they
have carefully studied the ways in which
they would communicate with
non-technical decision makers and help
them to make real choices because I
don't think you can solve that problem
without solving the explaining what
privacy means problem uh effectively
um but on the theoretical side of things
um
I'm hoping that there will be a move
towards more widespread agreements and
more prioritization of thinking about
the distinction between
um so we're working on a draft paper
right now where we talk about this as
the distinction between generalizable
inference and privacy violating
inference
um and I don't know if it's language
that will resonate with everyone uh
because we've had a lot of conversations
with
um both non-technical and Technical
folks I'm including sort of as an
example
um one of the the most fundamental
objections we've run into repeatedly
um with with very well-meaning groups
some who have studied this stuff
reasonably carefully uh
um
one of the the groups that reviewed
under contract the work that we did for
the Centennial census
um there is a quote very sort of pretty
deep in in their their publicly
available draft uh where they comment
um I think the phrase that the sentence
is something to the effect of uh the
relevant risk is the
um increase in uh inferential confidence
um from before the census was released
to after about an individual
um and this is this is the kind of
language that
feels very natural to people because
you're talking about an inference about
an individual and a inference they don't
want to happen about them it feels
personal and privacy violating but it's
also the kind of language that very
rapidly leads to the conclusion that the
only way to actually formalize privacy
is to kind of choose semantic categories
of things that we do and don't want to
be studyable and not to try to identify
that there is a particular like
actually formalizable
um for formerly specifiable kind of
knowledge that that is the is is what
corresponds to private information as in
this particular case
um that the really we've tried to move
backwards to the point where we have
like really clean clear-cut simple
intuitive examples that don't come with
many um theoretical elaborations on them
and so like the one that we've started
to use recently
um in one of our our non-technical
Publications was to talk about we'd like
whatever definition of privacy we commit
to um like I really probably shouldn't
speak for census here I would like us to
commit to a privacy definition that
allows us to publish at the state level
63 numbers characterizing the race
distribution of people in those States I
think any notion of privacy that doesn't
allow you to do that with a a low amount
of absolute error is probably not a
great privacy definition because we're
talking about an incredibly small not a
total number of scalar values there
um most of the populations involved are
incredibly large at the state level so
of intuitively you don't expect large
privacy concerns there if that's the
only thing you're talking about
publishing
um in this space the example that we've
been going to that I thought I built up
actually is in Montana
um in 2010 the Centennial census
published that about 90 of the
population self-reported that they were
white Alone um in the racial statistics
if you assume an attacker who had no
idea what the racial distribution was of
Montana before the census was released
well they've suddenly gained a whole lot
of confidence about just sort of an
arbitrary person if the only other thing
they know is that they live in Montana
this is exactly the kind of inference
that we want to be able to enable them
to make if you can't make that inference
then I'm not sure what the census is
doing you really aren't able to study
anything meaningful at that point
um so I guess I guess my hope is that
examples like this that are intended to
point out the consequences of a choice
of privacy definition can get us away
from looking at the stated definition
saying oh well that seems kind of
natural and reasonable and we listen to
a space where we're talking instead
about well
what things can we use as tests to rule
out certain privacy definitions is
unacceptable able and how can we use
that to get us to a space where we're
talking about a privacy definition that
is generally reasonable
all right great thank you Philip uh we
are out of time
briefly also hear from Samir what are
the some of the terminologies that folks
in Academia use and this that might
create some uh uh yeah there were short
on time but so I'll just make a call to
action
um yeah like the more you can simplify
things uh you know as you're
communicating with practitioners uh the
easier it's going to be
um I I you know the complexity that
Philip's talking about
um I appreciate that very much and then
at some point you have to distill it
down to where you can get to action so
um yeah I would think about it in terms
of like activism and movements and you
know what you're trying to accomplish uh
and if if um yeah another thing that uh
sticks out in that process is just
relationship building and how you build
those relationships with all the
stakeholders that are there and really
dig in on the empathy and compassion
that's necessary to have a real
conversation that's going to lead to
change
all right great that was an awesome
discussion we had many more questions
but unfortunately we are out of time so
please join me in thanking your five
panelists
thank you everyone for participating
thank you we do have a reception uh